So the answer is we need to find the second element of countries,
so that's this element.
Remember that lists are indexed starting from 0,
so to find the entry corresponding to India,
we need to find the entry at position 1.
The result of countries[1] will be the element of countries at that position,
which is the list containing 3 elements,
the string India, the string Delhi,
and the value 1210, which is the population of 1.2 billion people.
To select the capital, that's the second element of that list,
so we use index 1 again to get that element,
and the value of countries[1][1] will be Delhi.
And then we can just use print to print that out.
Let's try that in the interpreter.
So, running countries[1] will give us the element of countries
that corresponds to India.
And then to get the capital, we select element 1 from that.